(bright music)
- Well, welcome back to another
episode of the Addy Hour,
as always it's my honor and pleasure
to host these conversations.
Today I'm thrilled to be
able to host Juju Chang
for our conversation on society, culture,
and being a voice for
marginalized communities.
So this is a name that's probably familiar
to all of you as listeners,
but I'm gonna go ahead
and give Juju just a little
bit of an introduction.
So as you all likely know,
Juju Chang is an Emmy
Award winning co-anchor
of ABC News Nightline.
She also reports regularly
for Good Morning America and 2020.
Recently her decades
of reporting converged
in a way as she hosted
two hour long specials
about the rise of hate
crimes towards Asian American
and Pacific islander communities in 2021.
So very important work.
She is someone who's been recognized
for her indepth personal narratives
that have been set against a
backdrop of pressing national
and international news
from natural disasters
to terrorism and racial equity.
Just to highlight a few of the
stories that she has covered.
One was a critical examination
of the controversial Remain
in Mexico immigration policy,
her award-winning report
trans and targeted
on violence against transgender women
of color across the country,
and also her extensive coverage
of the COVID 19 pandemic,
the science, the economic
fallout, the racial disparities,
the impact on hospital
ICUs and essential workers.
Juju is someone who has
profiled numerous newsmaker
over the years, too many to list here,
but many who are influential
in lots of different spheres.
And I also want to mention she's a member
of the Council on Foreign
Relations and a founding member
of the Board of Korean
American Community Foundation.
So someone who's also been invested
in a lot of different ways.
So again, I'm grateful to be
able to welcome Juju Chang
to the Addy Hour podcast,
thanks for being here.
- I am so pleased to join you today.
- Excellent, wonderful to have you here.
And again, so many important things
that you have on which we'll touch on
as we go through the episode.
But as my listeners know,
and one of the things I
think my listeners appreciate
is just a chance for us to be able
to peel back the layers as it were.
So I wanted to start with
just a general check-in
and see how you're doing
at this point in time
at the end of April, 2022 with everything
that we're continuing to navigate.
How are you doing this point in time?
- It's so profoundly
lovely of you to do that
and do a mental health check in.
I'm okay right now.
It was rough going through the anniversary
of the Atlanta shootings.
I went back to Atlanta and talked
to victims families one year later.
And you tend to absorb a
lot of the traumatic stories
when you're in my line of work,
and there's something
called empathy trauma.
I've talked to sex crimes
prosecutors who have it,
and I've gone from chasing
Boko Haram in Africa
to the Pulse nightclub shooting,
and trying to just power through
and be a good journalist.
And don't just compact, compact, compact,
and then bursting into
tears at the drugstore.
Right now I'm okay, I've done a lot
of everything from therapy
to giggling with my
girlfriends to meditation.
But I will say that some of
my African American colleagues
did mental health check-ins with me
when at the height of the AAPI Hate.
It was a little bit unexpected.
So I literally started tearing up
and what everything that I'd
held back kind of poured out
in 30 seconds.
And then immediately I felt guilty
because for these same
African American colleagues,
I didn't do a mental health check in
to say, I know that this hurts
to watch numbers of your community.
I know that this hurts to
have to explain, I know.
And just that simple check
in meant so much to me.
I just assumed that my
colleagues knew how I felt
about their struggle and their pain.
But I had never expressed it before.
So I'm not only grateful to you,
but I would encourage
all of us to do check-ins
with our friends, and
colleagues and loved ones.
- So important and so well said.
And I'm just impressed,
thankful for your level of candor
and impressed that the process
that you even went through
of letting all those emotions out,
but also kind of catching
what was happening
in the midst of that as well.
And something that was
actually gonna tie back
into and just thinking
about the emotional toll
of the type of the work that you do.
I mean, it sounds like that
in itself may have been a journey,
and way that you let things
out all in that moment.
And I wonder if you've thought back
about how you have been processing a lot
of the different things
that you've been walking
through up to that point.
And if that was a shift?
- Yes, I think it has been a shift
in that sometimes like as a journalist
or maybe as a community
activist, or as a advocate,
you feel like you're doing something.
And that goes a long way to
helping you feel overwhelmed
or helpless in the face
of darkness, honestly.
But what I found is that when I was
in Chad, Cameroon and
Nigeria following the trail
of Boko Haram, I was
talking to young girls
who had literally watched
their whole families
be slaughtered in front of them,
who were kidnapped, held as sex slaves.
But they were talking to
me with a flat effect.
And you could just see
the trauma all over them.
And for some reason as an American,
you're kind of an arms length away
from not really
understanding what it's like
to have your village burned down
and to have your livestock slaughtered.
It's just a different life.
And, but I came back to the States
and literally within 10 days was
in Orlando outside the Pulse nightclub.
And interviewing a family who
had gone there on vacation.
And it happened to be an
African American family.
But they Googled best nightclub in Orlando
and they ended up at Pulse.
And when I went to the home,
I'm seeing the aunties like cooking dinner
for the children who are
completely traumatized by this.
And for some reason I
connected to their family more,
more viscerally.
And I just found that the
cumulative traumatic stories
was having an impact on me.
I could feel it, and yet
I kept holding it back.
And these young women were
describing watching the gunmen
in front of them walk back and forth.
And one looked her straight in
the eye and she played dead.
I mean, the presence of
mind, I don't even know.
And that's a trauma that
she'll be processing
for the rest of her life.
And so there are so many occasions
where I talk up to people
and hear their stories.
But in a similar vein, I was in Las Vegas
with the Vegas nightclub shooting.
And you'll recall that was the
one where there was a shooter
on the 32nd floor.
And he had luggage case
after luggage case full
of ammunition.
He was shooting down onto the concert.
And I was in interviewing
a young woman who was
in the hospital the next day.
And she said, we heard shots run out.
I was with my parents. It
was just the three of us.
And I started running, running, running,
running until I realized
my pants were wet.
And I looked down and
I thought that's blood.
And she'd been shot and
ran a quarter of a mile
with a bullet lodged in her hip.
And she said, "But
immediately out of nowhere,
I collapsed and a complete stranger,
an off-duty firefighter came
and started shielding me from the bullets
and administering first aid."
And then somebody else came
over with a makeshift gurney,
one of those like concert gates.
And the next day when I
interviewed the hospital workers,
they were like, there were so many people,
volunteers dragging
victims to the hospital.
And in my hospital room,
the woman with the bullet lodged still
in her hip said to me,
"You know what I saw? I saw
one bad man in the tower
and 100s of heroes here on the ground."
And she was like, I am so grateful.
And I thought in the face
of all of that darkness
you see goodness and you see hope.
And so that is what I cling
to when I tell these stories
of such darkness and depravity.
- That's such a helpful
perspective too as I imagine,
as you're going through all
these different components
and walking through with people,
and it's so helpful how she shared that.
'Cause even as you would
tell a story I was thinking,
oh, you're seeing the
hope in the midst of that,
the hope and the humanity and people.
To hear her put that in
context of one versus 100,
I think is so powerful.
- Totally, totally.
And I quote her to this
day, it's been years
and I was such a powerful moment.
- Really, really important.
And I imagine things like
that just keep you going.
But to step back even a little bit further
and to give our listeners
again a peek back,
I'm curious if you'd be willing
to share just how you even got
into this path in the first place?
What motivated you to get into reporting,
into journalism, into co-anchoring
and to bringing these stories,
these important stories
to such a larger audiences
in the way that you have so effectively?
- Well, two things,
my joke is that I basically
failed freshman calculus.
I've had feedback on this like
don't buy into these rumors
that these stereotypes,
that women are good at math, I was like,
oh no, that's not the stereotype.
I'm breaking the stereotype
that Asians are good at math.
So I feel like...
- You're safe.
- Exactly.
- In that comment.
- But like my well meaning
immigrant parents wanted me
to be an engineer.
So that's what I was gonna do at.
I was a freshman at Stanford
and I took a required
class in political science,
not because I wanted to,
but because I had to.
And I ended up getting an A+ in that class
at the same time that I got
a 27 out of 100 in calculus.
And I thought, huh, I feel
like the universe is trying
to tell me something.
And that combined with the fact that.
I think we talk about how
representation matters
and role models matter.
At the time Connie Chung
was a prominent Asian
American broadcaster.
And my mother was the one who said to me
that Connie Chung, you could be like her.
And it was that moment.
Like that's why role
models are so important
is because role models give
you permission to dream.
And that's what happened.
And it allowed me for the first time
to go against sort of what
my family, my culture,
everyone around me was
saying that I should do.
And then thirdly, I think
part of the reason why,
and I really have only thought
about this more recently.
But part of the reason why I
think I've always been drawn
to stories of marginalized
communities and the underdog,
and the powerless is that
that's the way I grew up.
I grew up an immigrant child from Korea.
I was born in Korea,
came to the Northern
California when I was four
and felt very much like an outsider.
Like it was Silicon Valley
before it was Silicon Valley.
So it was cherry orchards apricot trees.
And there was no some
advanced micro devices.
And I went to school thinking
that my family talked funny
and my family's food smelled funny.
And I was told on the playground a lot
that my face looked funny.
In fact, I tell the story that I used
to go to sleep at night
with scotch tape on my nose.
Because I wanted to wake up
and look like a California girl
with like not a flat nose.
So I watched my father be treated poorly,
and I didn't have words to
describe what I was witnessing.
Like today you would call
it racism or microaggression
or whatever.
But at the time I was a young girl
and I just knew that it wasn't right.
And I knew that it didn't feel right.
And I didn't like it.
And I still, I think I spent
the next 30 years seeing
the world through the
eyes of that young girl
who felt marginalized, who felt other,
who understood what it
means to be dismissed
or invisible, or all those things
that happened to marginalized community.
And so that's part of why I'm drawn
to stories on the border.
You mentioned the story
about "Remain in Mexico."
I went and did stories
about pregnant mothers,
bringing young children
and their unborn babies
to a better place.
Which is essentially what
happened to me at the age of four.
So I'm seeing like four year old kids
and I'm relating to them
in totally a different way.
It's why I went to Honduras
and did a whole series on femicide.
Why Honduras was one of
the most dangerous places
to be a woman and explored
why violence against women
is often sexualized,
it's often intimate partner violence.
It's often violence that
involves rampant guns
and lack of accountability.
And those are all things that happen
in societies at different levels.
And so it was a really, it
was they call it femicide.
Women would disappear and no
one would be held accountable.
There are so many
stories where I look back
and I realize I'm drawn to them
because I'm drawn to telling
the stories of the little guy.
- That's really, really
powerful the way you said that.
Was there a point that you feel
like you were able to start
to verbalize that?
I'm gonna assume that as a
four year old, probably not,
but there may have been
a path along the way.
'Cause even as you're
talking back through it,
seems like you can clearly
pick out specific instances
and situations that shaped
how you look at things.
But was the point where
you became more aware of it
and that you were able to verbalize that
and translate that into what
you were actually doing?
- I think it took a really long time.
I'm a little sick in the head, I guess.
I was more early on
interested in making my way
in the world.
And so I wasn't about my identity.
Like I think that's the big change.
Frankly for me I was part of the shift
in thinking after George Floyd's murder.
I just feel like I took inspiration
for my African American
colleagues who in that moment
for the first time
Pierre Thomas, like Sibos
and Sami some of my closest friends,
and colleagues of ABC News,
who I've known for 30 years,
who've never talked
about their upbringing,
their lived experience
into their reporting.
They started giving the
rest of the world insights
into what it's like to be a
black man driving home from work
and being pulled over.
And so I started doing that a bit
in my reporting, especially
with regard obviously
to AAPI Hate to talk about,
let me give you some perspective.
'Cause I had done that in other areas.
So like if I was doing
a story about parenting
or mommy angst, I would
bring my experience as a mom
into the story,
like what that would mean
nothing but a net gain.
So I realized that really
pretty late in life
that that's what my value
added was in a funny way.
And so I had founded this
Korean American Community Foundation,
which we're about to have our gala.
We raised $2 million
last year, like blossomed
into this huge undertaking.
But it was always something did
off camera, outside of work.
And now I've brought my understanding
and my identity more central.
And that has been a shift for me
that I don't know honestly,
if I can put pinpoint
when that happened, but it
was a slow burn for sure.
- Well, that's really helpful to know,
and just to see your process
and journey in that as well.
I mean, even to be honest,
some conversations I was having today,
even in terms of parallels
between the African American community,
the AAPI community and the things
that people are walking through.
But as you've mentioned, it
seems like the conversation
is shifting in the sense
that there's more openness
to speak about those things across group
and to have some aspects of similarity.
And this is a fresh thought
I'm still formulate.
But one thing I've also
noticed is there seems
to be some commonalities that were there,
that people are more able to talk about
in the ways that others aren't.
So I've even had members
within academic settings
from AAPI communities who have talked
about sometimes those
outs side their community
who don't know how to enter
into that conversation,
because they think they're going
to say something wrong, or
they're worried about missteps.
Whereas with African
Americans, they don't have
that same type of hesitation
because there it's a mutual experience
and language, so to speak,
even though it's not the same experience.
But there are so many
overlapping components
that people seem to be sharing
across the communities.
Again, this is a new
thought so it's not quite,
it's not coming out as
clearly as it is in my head.
But just something I'm starting
to know this over time as well.
I don't know if that's been
your experience as well.
- I think it's really important for us
to be able to have these conversations in
and not be afraid of offending each other
because that fear just
nips the conversation
in the bud before it even happens.
So an example that I often give is
I interviewed a non-binary
actor by the name
of Nico Tortorella.
And I sat down with him and I said,
I'm really sorry if I misgender you.
If I use the wrong pronoun,
I don't, you know, da, da.
And he, they said to
me, see they said to me,
"Juju, it's totally fine.
I understand that you're trying,
and that your intentions are good.
It really does matter
like where it comes from.
If somebody misgenders me with
hate then that's not okay.
But if somebody misgenders me
by accident in conversation,
I'm not gonna take offense to that."
And so I think that is the spirit
in which these conversations
need to happen.
We have to have that hold grace
between the person who's speaking
and the person who's listening.
I think we talked about Jeremy Lynn
and one of the most, I think classy ways
that he discussed a microaggression
or a slur that happened
to him on court was
somebody on court called him
the coronavirus or called
him China virus or something.
And afterwards, everybody the reporters,
nosy reporters like me were like
at the press conference saying,
"So who did it? Who did it? Who was it?"
And he said, "I have
no interest in shaming
or blaming anyone.
But I wanna call out the
behavior because if I don't,
then it's seen as okay."
And I thought that is such a great way
of looking at these conversations
because we can't learn unless
we have these conversations.
And yet at the same time we don't wanna be
just calling balls and
strikes all the time
and telling people that
what they said was wrong,
or hurtful or stupid, or worse.
- That's so well said.
And even that word, grace that
came up as you were talking
to that individual, I think
is huge just to have the grace
to be able to make those mistakes.
And it seems there's also
a level of trust there
that needs to be there,
trust that the people are coming
from the right place of intentionality.
And again, just having that place
to have that learning.
Because as you said, if
the mistakes don't happen,
then people won't learn.
And perhaps that's, again,
my neuroscience piece
that's coming out already,
but that's just what we learned
from those types of things
and how that also needs to be applied
in these situations as well.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- On that note, I also
was curious just about.
I mean, again, you've
done I keep going back to,
but just so much that
you've done to really have
and speak for so many marginalized
and "voiceless" communities.
Not that they don't have a voice,
but not to the level that they need to.
And I'm curious as you've been
doing this over the years,
are there specific aspects of your work
that have been both the most rewarding
and on the other side
the most challenging?
So I'll let you start with
whichever one of those one.
- Oh, so hard.
The most rewarding one I think was
at the Atlanta shooting
more than a year ago.
Because ABC News was the only network
who did a full prime time
hour following that shooting.
And I know that, that
wouldn't have happened were it
for the years and months
of work that I had done,
pre-interviewing people, doing
interviews with activists,
having everything sort
of locked and loaded
so that we could air it within 24 hours.
I remember flying down there
and we had booked the son of one victim
and the daughter of another victim.
And I was like so angry, 'cuz I was like,
once again we have to
crash this to the air
and we don't have time to do it.
I can't believe we have
to do this in 48 hours.
And I thought, actually it is in 48 hours.
I've been working steadily
towards telling this
particular story for 30 years.
Because how many mass shoot have I been to
and delicately had to
speak to a family member?
How many stories have I
done on human trafficking
and sex work, and what that
really means in a true sense?
And the geopolitics of it and the poverty,
and the deprivation and the
desperation surrounding it.
And how many of these stories
about AAPI Hate have I done?
And so all of that felt like
it was a true combination.
And so that was the story
that I was most proud of.
And we were able to really get at one
of the fundamental sort
of areas that is dicey,
which the hypersexualization
of Asian women.
And you'll recall there
was a county sheriff
who came out after speaking to the shooter
and saying, well, the shooter says,
he has a sex addiction and
he was trying to get rid
of his sex addiction.
So he says, it wasn't about
race, it was about sex.
At which point Asian American
activists came out very United
in their opposition to that idea.
This idea that the shooter
drove 25 plus miles,
past strip clubs, and porn
shops, and other sex work
and went at three
different Asian theme spas,
and conflated any Asian woman
in there as a sex worker.
And that is racialized at
the very least according
to so many of the experts that I spoke to.
So it was a galvanizing moment
in the Asian American community.
I interviewed two, as I
said, two victims children's.
One was a Chinese woman immigrant.
And she told the story about
her mother who'd come here
with nothing from a
rural province in China.
Who had worked after hours
to get a massage license.
Scraped together pennies,
worked six days a week,
ate from the rice maker in the back.
So she could save even more money.
So she could open her own spa.
And she had signs in every room that said,
no sex, no hanky panky.
And all of her friends said,
anytime anybody asked
for that kind of stuff,
they called the police.
And she was very, very
angry about that conflation.
Now the flip side of it is
I interviewed a young man
whose mother worked in a different spa,
and his name is Randall Park.
And he said to me, Randy Park.
And he said, "When I was growing up
that my mom worked in a beauty salon.
And, but when I got older,
I understood that it was shady."
That was the words that he used.
And he went and confronted his mother.
And I asked him what that
conversation was like.
And he said, would you
tell your son if you worked
in a spa like that?
And of course, he's like
about the age of my son
and I literally stopped short.
And I knew what I would say,
but I told him I'm a journalist.
And so I said to him that's
a really good question.
And he went on to say,
I told my mother, let's
not tell my little brother.
He said, but I want you to be safe.
I don't like that you lied to me.
And in closing,
in the same conversation this
21 year old young man said
to his mother, I will never shame you
for the decisions that you made.
'Cuz I know how hard you
worked to make sure that me
and my brother as a single mom were okay.
And I was just blown away by him.
And he had given up interviews like this,
and he went on GoFundMe
and he asked for a little
funeral expenses help.
Like we live hand to mouth.
I don't wanna lose this little
apartment to that we have.
Maybe you could just help me
with some funeral expenses.
And within 72 hours, he
raised more than $1.7 million.
And if you go online now and
you GoFund me, Randy Park,
he's closer to $3 million.
And I, of course was like,
what in the world is happening?
And so I scrolled through
all of the GoFund meets
and it was exactly what I said,
this idea that it had
this galvanizing impact.
That so many of the donations,
they weren't big dollar donations.
They were like $25, $75, $50.
And the notes and the
expressions were very similar.
They were like, we're really
sorry for your loss, Randy,
we see your pain, Randy,
my mother sacrificed like your mother.
And I'm so sorry for your loss.
On and on and on of
really just being seen.
And that struggle, that immigrant struggle
and sacrifice was really visible.
And so we were really proud
to be able to tell that story.
And we went back one year later.
Gave updates on a number of the victim.
It was an incredibly powerful
amount of storytelling.
So that was one that I'm most proud of.
In terms of the ones that
I've found most difficult is,
I have watched our community,
the Asian American community be held up
as the "model minority,"
which is as you know such mythology,
it's such out-and-out falsehood because,
again, I founded the Korean
American Community Foundation
predicated on the fact that
there's an 18% poverty rate
for Asian Americans in the tri-state area.
One in every four Korean Americans
in Northern New Jersey is uninsured.
Many are undocumented, many struggle,
and yet they're invisible.
These are the Asians that
are not the crazy rich Asians
that everyone thinks ends up at Yale.
They're the Asians who bring
you Chinese food dinner
or polish your nails in the nail salon,
or give you gas at the gas station,
or sell you liquor or the
dry cleaning or whatever.
And these are invisible, their struggle
and their pain is often in invisible.
And I think for me, it's been difficult
to watch our community.
It's hard because it's like,
oh, it's a good stereotype.
Why would you not like that?
It's like, well, not only
does it put undue pressure
on those in the community.
I'm sure you see it among
your Asian American students,
but it also, for those who
don't fit that stereotype,
it's a really negative.
And then that stereotype is used
to put our community against
other communities of color.
And so that is another sort of
pain point for our community.
It's led to so much misunderstanding
and at a time when we should be working
in solidarity on mutual.
We should all band together to
fight hate period, full stop.
White allies, Hispanic allies,
African American allies.
We should all be allied together.
And so to me it's been painful
to watch some of those stories emerge.
- Really well said.
I mean, so many things that resonate
and so much to unpack as well.
One thing that I want
to actually go back to
in the first story that
you were sharing about
that just being a galvanizing moment.
Because again having had a lot of
I've had Korean American
roommates in college
and a lot of other Asian American friends,
and just thinking about things
that have been happening over the years
that have not come to
the surface, so to speak.
I mean, even when you were talking
about the tragedy in Atlanta,
how your network was the only
network to do what you did.
And so I'm wondering how
that has been affecting
the Asian American community
already up till this point
and what you see as a shift.
'Cause even as you talked about,
you have been preparing
that story for years,
not just because of the
work you've been doing
around anti-Asian hate,
but because of the work you've been doing
around marginalization and
discrimination in general.
But again, it seems like
so much of it has been,
as you said, under the surface.
How do you see things shifting,
are there things that
are moving in the way
that they need to?
- I mean, I see a lot of
change in the last two years.
I think I started seeing it
in the Black Lives Matter protests.
'Cause as a journalist,
I was out covering those
protests face to police shield
in the middle of the mask protests.
But when I looked around,
I had covered many protests
in my 30 year career,
but these protestors
looked more like America.
They were parents and children
protesting, grandparents,
the black community,
obviously the Latino community.
I had never seen so many
Asian Americans protesting
for Black Lives Matter.
And I thought that was
such like an awakening.
And in many ways tool gathering,
if you know what I'm saying.
And it really, to me
opened people's hearts
and minds, I think.
And then when the AAPPI Hate
stuff started happening,
I really felt like I saw a maturation.
So the points of light to
me are the young activists
who were going to the olders
and saying, "You know what, mom, dad,
grandpa you're vulnerable.
And you can't stick
with the cultural norms
of keep your head down.
Don't say anything, don't raise ruckus.
You need to go and report this.
You need to go and make
your rights matter."
And I heard somebody, a
young comedian on TikTok.
My kids hate it when I mention TikTok,
but he said he was a, I
think he was a South Asian.
And he said, "My family
called it, the Uncle Sam tax.
They were willing to be treated
like second class citizens
because of the bounty
that this country offers.
And he said, but my generation,
we're not willing to do that.
We all took his AP history
and political science,
and we have the audacity to believe
that we deserve equal
protection under the law,
that we deserve equal rights,
that we therefore are Americans.
And it was such a powerful
kind of rallying cry
for a comedian, really lovely.
But I think that's kind of what I'm seeing
in the young generation.
I also think that I'm seeing
Jonathan Greenblatt of the ADL,
the anti-defamation like
runs the Center for Hate.
And he saw a lot of the
online hate spiking.
And he went to the
Asian American community
and warned them.
And that is how the Asian
American Foundation was created.
And it was launched by very
sort of powerful philanthropists,
including like Joe Tsai, Joe Bay,
Joe Tsai who owns the Nets.
Joe Bay, all these Jerry Yang,
Like all these very high profile people
who leveraged their considerable power
and wealth and founded the
Asian American Foundation
to help.
Again, this was the galvanizing
moment that happened.
And then I see like grassroots
community organizers,
people who are in Chinatown
who are like young kids,
who are like doing stuff.
And in Georgia, there was
a big get out the vote,
sort of enrollment and
were told by activists
that, that was the crucial margin
for the two Senate races in Georgia.
And I've seen Asian American organizations
over the years do like, oh,
let's ask for bilingual ballots,
let's look for more ballot access.
Let's do this kind of stuff
that literally the work of democracy.
And I think that, that has
accelerated because of this.
There are points of light, so to speak.
- That's really encouraging to hear.
I mean, just in the way
that some of those organizations
have come to light,
and the way that people have been invested
in that work as well,
and that's so important.
And of course, I'm always, again thinking
about the neuroscience and mental health.
I'm always just thinking
about just the tax as it were
of all these things on the
Asian American community.
And so I'm wondering if you'd be wanting
to share a little bit first
about just your perceptions
about mental health
conversations in AAPI communities
and how that intersects in a way
with all that's happened
around anti-Asian aid,
how that can also influence that,
and just if things are moving
in terms of conversation,
we had a little bit
of that conversation a couple
episodes ago with Jeremy Lynn,
as you mentioned, Esther Chiu,
but just curious to hear your
perspective on that as well.
- Well, I think there are
many different directions
to turn the telescope.
I mean, there's the I idea that
Asian American young people
are often suffering
higher rates of anxiety
and stress and depression,
because I think of the sort of pressure
of living up to the model minority myth.
Often when your parents,
when your parents have
sacrificed everything for you,
that's a lot of pressure, you
don't wanna screw that up.
And you feel very burdened by that.
At the same time, the Asian
American community is very,
I mean, I hate to speak broadly
'cuz we know the Asian American
community represents dozens
of countries and even more are cultures,
and languages and faith,
traditions and all of that.
But if I were to say
culturally Asian Americans,
there's a very big stigma
surrounding mental health.
There isn't a lot of open discussion.
There isn't a lot of
therapy, treatment options.
There isn't a lot in that space.
And then thirdly, I would
say, when you drill down
into these attacks, many
of them involve a component
of a mental health break on
the part of the perpetrators.
And we've seen that time and time again,
whether it's somebody who
walks into a black church
and kills parishioners.
Whether it's somebody who
walks into a Jewish synagogue
and kills parishioners,
or somebody who walks into
three Asian theme spas
and kills Asian Americans and bystanders.
This is disordered behavior.
This is mental illness.
And yet a lot of this
is reframed depending
on the circumstances.
And I think that ultimately
that is why dog whistles are so dangerous.
It's not because rational
people are gonna go out
and attack Asian people
because of the pandemic,
it's because irrational people may.
And there's a lot of
intersection of poverty
and homelessness, and
mental health crises.
And so the solutions are very complicated
and complex, and multi-layered,
and they are not.
Nothing's quick, there's no quick answers.
And so people who are like, oh, let's...
The other thing that's tricky
is that some of this flies
into the face of the defund debate.
Because there are those who argue,
well, we need more policing.
We need stronger police
presence, police force.
And then there are others who say,
no, this is exactly why we
need more mental health.
We need more culturally
competent police officers
who can speak the
different Asian languages,
and be culturally competent.
So that if somebody is victimized,
they're not afraid to go to the police
because in the old country,
you didn't go to the police.
That kind of stuff.
How do you get a hate crimes
charged when the witnesses
or the victim don't speak the language,
or not well enough to come up?
So there are so many complexities
that need to be examined.
Unfortunately, we don't have
a very patient political body.
And so these very nuanced solutions
and complicated solutions
are hard to get at,
to say the very least.
But I do think that it's from
a mental health perspective,
from neuroscience perspective,
so much of what we've endured
as a society during the
pandemic is flaring out.
I'm sure you would agree in
so many different spheres.
And so you're seeing this
giant uptick in gun violence,
you're seeing uptick in violent crime.
You're seeing an uptick in self harm.
You're seeing an uptick
in all of these mental health arenas
that again are often reframed.
And so hate crimes are sadly among them.
- And there's so many,
as you mentioned so
many things that we have
to pay attention to on
so many different scales.
I mean, even thinking
going back to childhood,
thinking about what needs
to happen in the schools,
because as students are
going through everything,
as parents are going through all that,
as those combined together,
all the anxieties uncertainties
that people are navigating simultaneously
in certain situations as
you add on top of that,
all the things like the stories
that you've been covering for
years are just gonna become
that much more exacerbated.
I think you're exactly
right in that component.
And yet at the same time, even
as you mentioned early on,
you still see these aspects
and these reasons for hope.
So even in the midst of that seems
that there's still something
that keeps you going on and
talking about these stories,
but then seeing the hope
that people are have having
to move forward as things have
been galvanized in a sense.
And I'm just curious what gives you hope
on a day to day basis?
'Cause I'm thinking
about being in your shoes
and just walking into certain situations,
how heavy that must be.
And how do you enter into that space
and how do you exit out that space
to still have hope for
the future going forward?
- It's a great question.
I've tried meditation.
I'm a lousy meditator.
- [Addy] That's good to know.
- Thank you. I try, I try.
There's a form of loving
kindness meditation
where you're supposed to meditate
and spread, loving kindness, whatever.
But at you start by sending
loving kindness to yourself.
And I think that, that
we be beat ourselves up.
We're so hard on ourselves.
We're so mean to ourselves.
I think that is a big part of
how I try to lift myself up.
I wanna share a story about
one victim I interviewed,
her name is Velma Carey,
Filipino American.
She was beaten up in front
of a Midtown high rise.
And the highlight of her beating was
that the lobby folks were
seen closing the door
as this beating was happening.
And later the building
said, "You only saw a part
of the clip you didn't see all of it."
But the bottom line was, it
created a lot of awareness
on her particular attack.
And so it took us weeks,
but we finally convinced her daughter
and her to sit down for an interview,
and they did such powerful stuff.
So they had too had done a GoFundMe.
They raised a couple $100,000
which was significant.
And the daughter took that money
and created a popup museum with stories.
So what happened was during
the attack, the attacker,
just again, to bring some
humanity to the attacker,
he was having a mental health break.
He was just let out of prison
for killing his own mother.
There was a tremendous
amount of trauma there
and he beat up this random woman and said,
"You Asian B word, you don't belong here."
And so the daughter took these stories
of belonging from the AAPI community
and created exhibits using these words,
and entitled it AAPI Belong.
And so then I'm sitting down
with Velma and her daughter,
and Velma says, I said,
"So, did you ever make it
to St Patrick's Cathedral?
'Cuz I heard that was where
you were headed that day."
And she said, "Yes I did. I
went for my 60th birthday."
I said, "What did you pray for?"
And she just had this
big smile on her face.
And she said, "Prayers of gratitude."
She said, "We had so much
loving outpouring of food.
People were sending food and gifts
and notes of encouragement
and money and the GoFundMe.
And I couldn't believe like
how much people she showed
their compassion to me."
And then she looked at her daughter
and she looked at me and she said,
"And then I prayed for my attacker."
And literally the camera on me
at the moment was like this.
And I said, "Wow, why,
why did you do that?"
And she said, "Because whatever
was going on in his mind,
I wanted to give him grace."
That was literally the
words that she used.
And I sat there for a
second and I said to her,
again, I've been doing this for 30 years
and I've talked to a lot of
people about a lot of things.
And I said, but I know
enough whether you look at it
from the neuroscience perspective
or from the spiritual
perspective or from the
philosophical perspective,
that like that act of
forgiving someone does as much,
if not more to empower the
person who's doing the forgiving
then it does bestow on the
person who's being forgiven.
And so in that moment I said to her,
"You know what's really crazy, Velma
is that you're literally
fighting hate with love."
And it was just such a
powerful moment for me.
And I thought it was
so obviously so genuine
from her sort of Catholic perspective.
And so that's the kind of stuff
that gives me hope that
like makes me think
that we can turn this a hateful
act into an piece of art.
AAPI Belong to turn victimization
into something more
powerful and meaningful.
And then to take this incident
and surround it with meaning.
- Wow. That's so beautiful.
So well said.
- Crazy right? I know she was so powerful.
- And you also, you took
the words out of my mouth
in terms of that holistic
approach to thing as well.
'Cause I mean, that's so
much of what we talk about
on this podcast,
thinking about all those
different perspectives,
whether like you said, neuroscience,
the spiritual component,
the psychological component
and how all these things intersect.
And so I think that's just
a beautiful encapsulation
of all that.
And it's so important.
I mean, I'm trying not
to pull in all the neuroscience,
but what that does, all those
components what those do
to our brains and how that helps us
to come up with different
coping strategies
and to move through.
Even in our last conversation,
we had a conversation with
a psychiatrist who also
is a man of faith and talked
about all the evidence
for the spiritual practices
when they are tied together
with different
psychological interventions,
and how powerful that can be.
And it seems like even
that's not your profession,
how you've seen that at work
in so many different ways.
That's really, really powerful
and really encouraging
to hear about as well.
The one piece I was also gonna ask
about as we wrap up is just your,
I know this may feel a little bit,
like I'm pulling it back in,
but just thinking about
your faith walk as well
as you are someone who grew up
in a Korean American household,
but then also converted
to Judaism at one point.
And so, as you know as
we brought that part
into the conversation curious
how that journey came about
and how that has also
impacted your outlook
on all the work that you do?
- I was the reluctant Jew.
I've actually never you used that phrase,
but I think it's true.
I married a nice Jewish
guy named Neil Shapiro
and I told him when we were dating
and after we got married that
I was never gonna convert.
So like end of topic, move on.
I was raised as this you know I felt
I was very proud secular humanist.
And I was maybe a little bit
of a situational emphasis,
but whatever.
But after like a dozen years together
after having some kids,
or one kid at the time,
we ended up having three boys.
But at the time one,
I realized I really drew a lot
of energy from the rituals,
from the philosophy, from the thinking,
from the thoughtfulness of Judaism.
And so one day I literally said
to my husband over breakfast,
like, I think I'm gonna convert.
And he literally did
one of the, like what?
And what was great is
we spent a year going
to like introduction to
Judaism classes together.
We talked about things that
we've never talked about
in the dozen years we've been together.
And that was what was so enriching
and in an interesting
way, it changed his view
of his own Judaism.
Because the rabbi went
from the guy up on the Bema
to the guy sitting next to us
chatting about the Yankees.
And so that changed his perspective too.
And for me we've been
part of the lay leadership
in the congregation.
Our kids are very identified,
very strongly as both
Jews and Korean Americans.
The joke in our house is
that they're 50% Korean
and 100% Jewish.
And so it's been an
incredible source of strength,
and family, and love like,
we just last week, I hosted two seders.
I make a pretty good latka
and you're welcome to come next time.
And my meatball soup,
even though the meatballs are from a box
are still pretty good.
- [Addy] That still
works. That still works.
- It still works.
I cut some corners here and there.
It's really part of our family tradition.
bUt I also make dumplings from
scratch and rice cake soup
for new year's day.
And so I feel like my faith is something
that it literally was an act of faith
to decide that I wanted to be a Jew.
And live as one.
- Has that shaped your perspective
in your work after that conversion?
- Think so.
Absolutely, I mean it kind of dovetails
because at the seder every year,
we talk about treating strangers,
remembering to be kind to strangers
because you are one
strangers in a strange land.
To understand that oppression
everywhere is anywhere
is something that Jews stand up against.
And it's so interesting
that it into weaving,
like right now, I told you
the story about the ADL
and the AAPI community.
And I talk often about how
Frederick Douglas spoke out
against the Chinese Exclusion
Act back at the time
in the 1880s.
And how the Jews worked
in the civil rights sphere
and in that historical brotherhood really.
And that is something that I
wish was a better understood
than the things that I see right now,
especially online where hate gets clicks.
And there's a lot of anti this, anti that.
You are stepping out you're
this, and there's this,
like don't compare your pain to my pain.
Like, there's a lot of animosity
when there's really a
lot of shared history
and shared goals really.
So yes, that's been a large
part of my faith journey
and it's informed all
of it in different ways.
- Very encouraging to hear.
And there's great perspective as well.
I mean, both your journey
and the story that you shared
of the individual just
that aspect of grace
and forgiveness is tremendous, tremendous.
Well, thank you so much.
We've covered a lot of different topics.
I really enjoy just having
this free flowing conversation.
And just, again, all the
work that you've done
to bring so many important stories to life
and to larger audiences,
and hopefully to help us
move forward as a society
to a better place as well.
Definitely appreciate you
taking the time to be here
to share a little bit about your journey
and about the path that you place
and the ways that you're
speaking up on behalf of so many.
Thank you so much for taking time
to be here on the Addy Hour.
- Thank you, Dr. Addy, and
I am a huge fan of your work
and wanna dig into it.
So someday I could interview you.
- That would be wonderful.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate the investment
and I may take you up
on that offer as well.
I think our listeners would
definitely enjoy that.
- I know they would.
- Excellent. Thanks so much.
- All right, bye.
(bright music)